apropos gespräche dann steigen wir
nochmal einen diesen langen live
nachmittag hier bei phoenix zusammen mit
dr christian hornig parteienforscher vom
liechtenstein institut hat er doktor und
hallo grüße sie herr hornig also alle
sprechen über die
regierungskonstellation zukünftige
regierung alles schön und gut machen wir
natürlich auch gleich meine damen und
herren aber einmal vorab dieser tag
heute im bundestag was bedeutet der na
ja wir haben erstmal den bundestag
gewählt nicht die regierung und der
bundestag die legislative ist die
herzkammer der demokratie und das ist
heute glaube ich ein aufregender tag
viele neue abgeordnete müssen erstmal
ihre büros beziehen das sind ganz
praktische dinge man muss sich
orientieren man muss seine ausweiskarten
abholen damit das parlament überhaupt
die arbeit anfangen kann also da wird
heute ordentlich rum gewählt werden und
da munter november nachher auch noch mal
genau darauf schauen haben wir den ein
oder anderen die eine andere abgeordnete
auch begleitet an ihrem ersten tag herr
hornig trotzdem und wir sprechen überall
das gleiche intensiver im laufe dieser
sendung aber trotzdem schon mal der
blick natürlich auf das was seit sonntag
habe das große thema ist zukünftige
regierung mehr macht
das kann ich noch nicht so ganz
voraussagen aber es ist natürlich
spannend die parteien schütteln sich
jetzt nach der wahl es ist ein erdbeben
gewesen das muss man ehrlicherweise
sagen und jetzt wird kommt es darauf an
wie verhandelt wird hinter den kulissen
wer sich damit neben einigen kann
thematische schwerpunkte spielen
natürlich eine rolle aber eben auch
persönliche beziehungen erdbeben nur
noch kurz haben sie gesagt was meinen
sie mit erdbeben naja wenn die größte
regierungspartei massiv verliert und der
machtverlust droht dann ist das schon
ein erdbeben nach 16 langen
regierungsjahren und eine neue koalition
an die regierung kommt ein neuer
regierungschef wahrscheinlich ins
bundeskanzleramt einzieht dann ist das
schon eine gewaltige veränderung
genau darüber wollen wir sprechen im
laufe dieses nachmittags meine damen und
herren und arbeiten ab eins nach dem
anderen was wir bisher erlebt haben und
was live drüben in berlin passiert und
deswegen gucken wir erst mal auf rolf
mützenich den fraktionschef der spd
wir haben es eben gehört die spd hat
eingeladen die sondierungsgespräche
sollen diese woche beginnen eike
christian hornig parteienforscher man
hat fast so ein bisschen das gefühl dass
der wahlgewinner die spd trotzdem
irgendwie so ein bisschen in der
bittsteller rolle ist so bitte liebe
grüne liebe fdp lasst uns doch mal diese
woche beginnen und trefft euch nicht nur
alleine naja die erste frage wer ist die
spd der wahlgewinner also das kann man
da kann man ja darüber diskutieren ich
meine die haben sich das an na ja sie
haben vorsprung ja sie sind die stärkste
fraktion das ist natürlich richtig
also ist haben wir nochmal das papier
ich gehöre noch mal mit 5,2 prozent zu
wachsen um 5,9 also ein bisschen mehr
grün hat ein bisschen mehr erhofft die
spd so lange er doch als der verlierer
aus würden sie sagen sie sind nicht mehr
gewinnen das finde ich nicht sagen aber
ich diese referenz auch die wahlumfragen
die dürfen das nicht ersetzen wie wir
sozusagen tatsächlich auf die
wahlergebnisse gucken also wir haben
jetzt eine situation die lachse partei
oder fraktion genau also stellt sich als
stärkster fraktion so das ist natürlich
auch richtig und es spielt auch eine
rolle aber es ist ja auch sehr
diskutiert worden jetzt seit sonntag
sozusagen ist das thema
regierungsauftrag tisch stellen sich hin
ja ja wir haben klaren regierungsauftrag
ist das eben nicht mehr und wir sind
gesehen da kommen und das meine ich auch
mit den erdbebenfolgen da kommt jetzt
einiges ins wanken die großen parteien
sind es eigentlich gewohnt gewesen so
ich nehme den hörern die hand und ruft
jetzt an und sagt was auch wir treffen
uns dann und dann bekommt ihr bitte soll
jetzt stellt sich linda und und die
grünen stellen sich hin und sagen wir
reden erst mal alleine miteinander da
gucken die großen natürlich erstmal
etwas kopiert und sagen das ist an uns
klar ist macht die spd jetzt tempo weil
sie will will ja selber das heft des
handelns in der hand haben und auch
signalisieren wir sind es jetzt diese
zeit voran gehen und diese regierung
formen wir haben ja auch den
kanzlerkandidaten der sozusagen den
größten zuspruch erhalten hat aber das
bild ist nicht mehr so ganz klar wie es
früher einmal war sehr spannend oder
schaut es hat ja gesagt nein das ist für
mich schon in ordnung dass die sich
zuerst treffen aber was soll er auch
anderes sagen bleibt das denn der rote
faden aus ihrer sicht also jetzt treffen
sich grüne und fdp im laufe dieser woche
kommen dazu gleich noch mal dann gibt es
die ersten sondierungsgespräche bleibt
es so dass am ende möglicherweise wie
die grünen und die fdp angeles sid also
im fahrersitz bleiben und im endeffekt
bestimmen wo wie was und die spd als
dann doch deutlich stärkere datei als
die anderen beiden vielleicht eher so
mit hecheln darf also ganz
hinterherlaufen die spd ist geht ja auch
ins kanzleramt aber ich glaube das ist
eine folge der letzten
koalitionsverhandlung und ich mache dies
die fdp hat unter dem wir wollen lieber
nicht regieren als falsch regieren da
haben sie im nachhinein sehr darunter
gelitten das ist ein ziemlich um die
ohren geflogen und jetzt muss man da
anders an die sache rangehen also die
fdp braucht auch nach außen hin für die
kommunikation auch für die mitglieder
einen klaren erfolg ein klares thema das
sie ins schaufenster stellen können und
sagen hier diesmal ist alles anders wir
sind sozusagen diejenigen gewesen die
nicht abseits standen sondern wir haben
wesentlich auf dieses ergebnis hin
gearbeitet dann läuft das gleich ganz
anders da kann man mal zu den
potenziellen partner neben das
nachrichtenmagazin der spiegel berichtet
heute dass morgen ist das erste
gemeinsame treffen von grünen und fdp
geben soll christian lindner und sein
generalsekretär volker wissing für die
fdp und robert habeck und annalena
baerbock für die grünen jetzt hat aber
eben marco buschmann der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der fdp
bei uns hierbei für nichts gesagt nein
er will dazu nicht sagen er kann das
nicht bestätigen will dem aber auch
nicht widersprechen gucken wir auf das
was eben gerade die grünen gesagt haben
ich gehe wieder mal nämlich wege herr dr
harnik robert habeck hat heute in der
neuen osnabrücker zeitung sagt es muss
darum gehen in diesen möglichen
sondierungsgesprächen was können wir
eigentlich gemeinsam gut machen und
nicht was trennt uns kann das klappen
wird das klappen zwischen grünen der fdp
und dann wahrscheinlich der spd das kann
klappen
also es kommt immer darauf an nicht mal
der ton macht auch die musik das haben
wir nun schon gehörig mal positive
einstieg ist das ja und man wird
sicherlich etwas um räumen müssen im
kopf und in den inhaltlichen punkten um
sich da nicht komplett im weg zu stehen
aber klar es sind am ende demokratische
parteien und das gibt jetzt die
notwendigkeit die regierung zu bilden
irgendwie wird es schon gehen also bei
den sondierungsgesprächen 20 17 war es
ja umgekehrt da hat man ja erst mal
aufschreiben sollen was ein eigentlich
trend das ist jetzt schon mal einen
gedanken umkehr sehen sie das aus na ja
da ist es einfach ein enormer druck da
ist also letztes mal ging es bis in den
märz hinein das will eigentlich keiner
mehr haben die situation ist verworren
genug vorher wusste auch keiner was
kommt jetzt eine koalition hinter wissen
wir dass auch noch nicht so recht die
leute warten glaube ich darauf dass es
endlich losgeht mit der neuen regierung
und insofern kann man sich das glaube
ich nicht erlauben jetzt an jedem komma
hängen zu bleiben ist letzte frage
inhaltlich kommt man denn da zusammen
aus ihrer sicht fdp grüne spd naja
manchmal wir haben den wahlkampf kann
erlebt also man wir haben große
unterschiede gesehen aber es gibt in der
politik immer mittel und wege wie man
über kompromiss techniken oder über
längere zeit läufe über also zeigen
verschiedene töpfe wo man was
mitfinanziert wo man zu kompromissen
kommen kann das geht immer man muss nur
den willen haben